hundreds of coup supporters have
gathered near a French base in Niger
they're also voicing anger at the West
African block ecowas while leaders
agreed to activate a standby military
force after holding an emergency Summit
in Abuja on Thursday defense Chiefs will
meet in Ghana next week to discuss the
plan the African Union has extended its
support to ecowas to end nichir's
military takeover
or Malcolm Webb is monitoring
developments for us in Senegal's capital
Dakar Malcolm what's the latest on the
ground in Niger
well it was just a short while ago that
hundreds of protesters gathered outside
a French military base that's near the
airport near the capital near me now
France had evacuated soldiers from one
of its military bases that was outside
of the city beyond the stand there was
still some French soldiers in this base
near the airport where there are now
hundreds of people outside cheering and
shouting and as you mentioned uh calling
for France and ecowas to uh to stand
back and to leave and to to leave them
alone now France said it had evacuated
all of its citizens from Niger eight
days ago but we understand there's still
a handful of soldiers left in this base
near the airport and that's who these
protesters are demanding should now
leave this obviously happens at the same
time that ikawas is placed its forces on
standby what's the latest with them
well the African unions just said that
it would support uh ecowas's uh decision
to or any decisions that they make it
also expressed concern uh about what it
describes as the deteriorating
conditions uh of President uh the ousted
president Muhammad bazoom ekowas heads
of State on a meeting on Thursday said
that they would proceed to put together
a standby Force the military Chiefs are
due to meet next week it's still not
known how many troops would come and
from which country most of the leaders
would still have to clear this through
their own uh governments to uh to to get
permission to be able to deploy military
forces in 2017 when ecowas deployed a
force to Gambia it took about a month to
put it together and that was a
relatively simple deployment Into The
Gambia which is an enclave of Senegal
whereas the deployment to Nigeria would
potentially be a lot more ambitious and
a lot more complicated and this still
comes just when Russia's finest foreign
Ministry has commented on this possible
deployment saying that the regional
deployment would have a stabilizing
effect across the whole destabilizing
effect across the whole region okay
thank you so much Malcolm that is
Malcolm Webb for us in Dakar